toute nouveauté technologique qui
s'installe dans la société doit faire
l'objet d'un débat démocratique
comment penser qu' on a des caisses
automatiques par exemple qui
s'installent dans les supermarchés sans
que ça fasse l'objet du moindre débat
avec les premiers qui ont concerné qui
sont les caissières comment on peut
penser qu'on installe la commande
numérique dans les ateliers de
logistique sans que donc avec des gens
qui ont un casque comme mais c'est un
plus gros casque que moi là et qui
répond ok ok ok quand la machine leur
dit allez trois ans gf et ainsi de suite
toute la journée qu'ils rentrent le soir
de leur maison utilise ok ok ok évoqué à
leur femme et que ça ça s'installe sans
que ça fasse l'objet d'une discussion
avec les premiers concernés c'est à dire
les caristes donc je pense que déjà là
le prix est le préalable à tout ça c'est
d'avoir une discussion avec les premiers
concernés commencent à s'installer
généralement le lieu le terrain de jeu
du capital
c'est l'entreprise c'est là qu'ils que
s'installe les avancées technologiques
et avec pour but des gains de
productivité mais comment ces gains de
productivité sont redistribuées la fiche
de paye des caristes dont je parle elle
n'a pas évolué et là il n'y a pas eu de
diminution du taux 1
en revanche chez bayard des économies de
coûts de production il va y avoir des
ateliers qui vont être fermées ainsi
suit donc simplement quand il ya une
avancée technologique je pense que la
démocratie elle peut se demander si elle
ne la souhaite aussi à la souhaitent pas
et dans mon livre je rappelle on connaît
l'épisode des lui dit
mais karl marx dont le capital est il
rappelle tous les épisodes ou des cités
ont choisi de ne pas installer des
métier de tapissier de tisserands et
tout ça en songeant à la misère et à la
colère que ça allait produire et c'est
peut-être un réflexe qui n'était pas
mauvais là quand on entend le discours
du gouvernement l'un des maître mots la
start up nation c'est accélérer
accélérer accélérer accélérer accélérer
on peut se demander quand même trop
aller où
[Musique]